obviously very very different experience
working on something like Sherlock we
always came back for series who you've
been working on it was it like working
on such a huge show like that and
experience as a director I very
different different part of me it's you
know there's a part of me is very taken
very clinical and I like a cool sort of
controlled environment I like you know
they're amazing actors so I love that
side of it this was very free and I had
a lot of fluidity so they're two part of
me that was satisfied in the different
jobs what it kind of the pressures of
working on something like Sherlock
compared to working on something like in
fear I think got a responsibility to the
fan base you know genuinely in fear you
know I only feel that today that there's
a fan base thing or a fan that I respect
and I want to know what they feel
Sherlock as the fan base come with it
and you kind of go see I've got to get
this right but it is a script it's not
you know it's written already so what
was it like working with Benedict
Cumberbatch and Martin Freeman on shadow
I love them as 11 their genius Martin is
his comic timing is beyond second to
none Benedict's very funny and brilliant
and there were moments where I genuinely
felt massively inspired I felt very
lucky actually to be working then it's a
difficult when you're working under such
a glare of publicity cuz there's been so
much kind of people trying to find out
is Andrew are gonna be there is no
reality what's happening with you
Benedict coming back I Schurrle
no that was fine I mean it was there's a
lot of people who follow you around we
did a few false shot you know there will
be things that people saw nothing to do
is it that way you handled
you